[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on est avec
maïwenn et français marcus est ce que tu
peux nous expliquer en quoi est ce que
ta solution est de marcoule dans la vie
de tous les jours
4 faites ça va changer
les chats et de leurs propriétaires en
fait on a développé un distributeur
connectés d'eau et de trotter pourchasse
que vous contrôlez depuis une
application sur votre téléphone sur
votre tablette est donc tout simplement
depuis cette application vous pouvez
programmer la dissolution des croquettes
et d'eau mais suivant elle souffre est
chaste aliments bien et connaître l'état
des stocks
des problèmes comment est ce que 2
quatre stades du mois peut détecter la
présence de marcus savoir où il en est
au niveau de sa consommation d'eau et 2
et de gros 4 sur l'application il ya
deux programmes de distribution soit le
chat ne s'était pas se rationner et on
mettait un programme de l'as tribution
alors fixe toute la journée soit le
châssis faut rationner à ce moment là
quand il va s'accrocher ducasse med
l'innovation majeure du produit/service
densification en fait on a une antenne
rfid qui va détecter la piste
vétérinaire vous chargez on propose en
médaillon si le chat et papiers et à ce
moment là dès qu'ils veulent détecter
savall a distribué une ration projette
lui activé la fontaine à eau
et
et vous pouvez mettre un maximum par
jour justement pour limiter sa
consommation éviter qu'ils écrivent
encore 40% des chats sont des zones
aujourd'hui en france c'est vrai qu'on
fait la régulation pour un autre petit
charles fatima frustrant terme du
prophète on peut mettre tous confiance
aux marchés
on a testé tous types de requêtes
regardez
quand quatre vétérinaires
l'application du coup à ios android
j'imagine exactement elle est disponible
aujourd'hui en
en téléchargement pour le test sur
android et bientôt sur aion
[Musique]
bon coup pour retrouver le soleil
johnny je sais pas avant j'avais peur
des voix il disait les vidéos qu'on peut
trouver l'application votre solution
peut la trouver ou alors sur quatre
banques casse-pot quoi vous qu'elle juge
va loin dans la description
merci à toi on voit autre chose à nous
rajouter pour notre petit marcus ou fort
et b venez nous voir on est au belge
félix pendant deux jours
n'y allons perdre et marcus tout et on
se retrouve au csv grâce à des projets
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo m'a
dit mon commentaire vous avez des chats
est ce que vous avez des problèmes quand
vous partez pour le non-dit asimov
appelé de gens appeler des amis
et est ce que je fous cette solution
pourrait vous aider vous mettez tout ça
en commentaire on en parle ensemble sous
sa mitaine mais c'est joli vous vous
êtes ric ur pezh pâte à pizza bonne amie
shine on se retrouve très bientôt d'ici
là soyez sages tiens